importing formula is illegal but when
you're trying to feed your baby
you do whatever you do the baby formula
shortage of 2022 turned a bunch of
parents like that mom into black market
Outlaws parents all over the U.S
scrambled to find baby formula last year
after supply chain issues left grocery
store shelves bare some even shared
hacks and ideas on social media for
illegally importing formula Europe as it
turns out has a lot of baby formula some
of the world's largest formula
manufacturers are based there so why
couldn't those European companies sell
that formula here because our government
doesn't let them FDA labeling
regulations and huge tariffs of 25
percent make it difficult or impossible
for American parents to buy formula from
overseas Congress temporarily lifted
those tariffs last year to help solve
the shortage but now they're back which
means another domestic Supply crunch
could turn another bunch of new parents
into part-time lawbreakers again